one of the biggest questions if elon
musk does successfully purchase twitter
is whether he's going to let donald
trump back on twitter donald trump was
banned from twitter permanently in 2021
uh remember there are some who say that
trump was banned from twitter in order
to hurt him in the 2020 election he
wasn't banned until 2021 so assuming
time moves forward
which i think we sort of think it does
uh unless you want to get into some
metaphysical stuff um that isn't true
but trump was banned from twitter in
2021 elon musk was recently asked would
you let him back on twitter
and elon musk said that he would now i
have some thoughts about this that some
in my audience may not agree with i'll
get to those in a moment let's first
listen to what elon musk said
are you planning to let donald trump
back on
well i
i think there's
there's a general question
of should was twitter have permanent
bands
um
and you know i've talked with jack
dorsey about this and
he and i are of the same mind which is
that
permanent fans should be uh extremely
rare and really reserved for
uh
people where they're trying to
uh before for accounts that are
bots or
spam scam accounts
where there's just no legitimacy to the
account at all
um
i i do think that uh
it was not correct
to
ban donald trump i think that was that
was a mistake
because it uh
it alienated a large part of the country
and did not ultimately result in donald
trump not having a voice he is not going
to be on truth social um as will a large
part of the sort of the the
right in the in the united states
um and so
i think this could end up being frankly
worse than having a sin you know single
form where everyone can debate
um
so um
i i guess the answer is that i i i would
reverse the permaban i will say i'm not
i don't own twitter yet so this is not
like a thing that will definitely happen
because what if i don't own twitter
but my opinion and jack dorsey i want to
be clear shares this opinion uh is that
we should not have perma-permanent bans
um now now that doesn't okay
so elon musk says he thinks trump was
wrongly banned now
uh donald trump was rightly banned let's
go through this in stages okay
um trump broke twitter terms of service
absolutely trump should have been banned
however i am very much in the direction
of
lifetime bans should be extremely rare
and trump probably shouldn't have gotten
a lifetime ban i'm not saying he should
be unbanned today i would be completely
fine with it having been okay
you incite violence that's a five-year
ban or ten or three or it doesn't even
really matter the specifics of it
but i generally don't believe in
irreversible decisions not that a
twitter ban is like the death penalty
but i am against the death penalty
because if you make a mistake you can't
undo it once you've executed somebody so
permanent bans for bot accounts
um accounts that are fake pretending to
be someone else impersonation
um automated activity absolutely no no
question about that those are bans for
life that's just a purging trash right i
mean we do we we permaban all of that
stuff on uh you know on all of our
platforms when we see it when we see
that type of thing
when it comes to
violations of terms of service i still
am okay with some bans for life but
they've got to be like i don't even know
you know you live stream yourself
committing a crime murdering someone
what a lifetime ban youtube does that
all that that that's okay
but even as bad as what trump did was
and he did really bad things i mean you
you can argue that his actions
you can argue his actions in total and
twitter was part of it led to real world
violence and it's terrible and he should
have been banned i still lean towards
most cases are a ban for a specific
amount of time
subject to review and revision and i
would be fine for that review and
revision to determine trump gets another
three years or whatever i'm totally
totally fine with that
but i would lean heavily in the
direction of
uh these are for a sort of specified
amount of time in general now
when when we talk about trump
specifically realistically
he may never change
uh
and he might get back on and do the
exact same stuff
um in which case you might say well
there's no reason to think he'd do
anything differently and so we're going
to keep him banned i'm fine with that
the other problem there's there's two
other problems with this anyway and it's
sort of like a fraught question one is
we know that terms of service are
inconsistently applied they're
inconsistently applied in different
cases based on how prominent accounts
are and they're inconsistently applied
also uh just on the basis of content we
that's just a thing and i'm not saying
that they're inconsistently applied in
terms of a left or right wing bias that
is a debate but i'm not even dipping
into that right now just terms of
service are inconsistently applied and
we experience that as well
there are on youtube for example
there are
because our content is seen by more
people than channels with a thousand
subscribers
there are lots of things we get
demonetized for that other really small
channels don't get hit with just because
no one's paying attention and you can
argue that that's right or wrong or
whatever but we have an inconsistent
application of terms of service and then
the other thing is
i am right there with you
that the idea of the bans get reviewed
who does the reviewing and do we trust
them to do the reviewing and i don't
have an answer to that right now so i'm
speaking in principle
i think for the most part we should
almost never have bands for life extend
them whatever almost like a parole
hearing i'm fine with that do you trust
the people you put in charge to do it
becomes a real question
as i've said many times before i believe
that the secret to
personal finance and it's not really a
secret isn't about timing the market or
picking individual stocks it's basically
asset allocation and in order to
determine asset allocation you've got to
know all of the different assets that
are out there that's why i joined a
community called alts and we asked them
to be a sponsor alts is a newsletter
that makes the world of alternative
assets accessible to anyone even if
you're new to it alt does the research
on alternative assets that no one else
is doing right now and they break it
down for readers in a way that's nuanced
and it's easy to digest and honest and
provides you with just a ton of valuable
insight into what assets are there and
this could be baseball cards
collectibles music rights comic books
video games the alts newsletter
demystifies
these investment markets for you their
recommendations have a track record that
you can check out on their website and
you can also learn about the alts one
fund which contains a blend of
alternative assets including
collectibles and art and music rights
and the things that i've mentioned you
can find that and the free newsletter at
davidpakman.com
slash alts the link is down below